de la fraude à l'assurance maladie est
particulièrement complexe qui touche les
comptes de l'Assurance Maladie relève
d'un calcul presque ça vaut pourtant
plus de 400 million d'euros de préjudice
ont déjà été détecté sur les 2 dernières
années un montant qui selon les deux
derniers rapport au du vin 2020 par la
Cour des comptes et l'Assemblée
nationale pourrait s'avérer bien plus
alors quelle est l'ampleur de la fraude
à l'assurance maladie en France et qui
en profite réponse dans facture
maintenir un système social protecteur
et bien il faut absolument lutter contre
les fautes parce que les autres
contribuer à développer des inégalités
de la Cour des comptes et qu'en France
nous comptons 2,4 mignon d'assurer de
trop qu'on ne s'est pas identifié en
comparant les chiffres de l'Insee sur la
population vivant en France et le nombre
d'assurés sociaux des différents régime
d'assurance maladie au 1er janvier 2020
les rapports rendu sont arrivés à ce
constat il y avait 71,3 million de
droits ouverts au système national
d'information interrégimes de
l'assurance maladie alors que le nombre
théorique maximale de bénéficiaire
n'était que de 68,9 million de personnes
ce qui fait 2,4 million de personnes en
trop la question qui sont les
bénéficiaires qui possède des droits
ouverts à une prise en charge des frais
de santé exercer ou non auditionné sous
serment par les membres de la commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur le sujet la
direction de la sécurité sociale
explique que cela pourrait être des
personnes qui fraude l'assurance maladie
seul ou en bande organisée des personnes
qui réussissent à s'inscrire au
répertoire national commun de la
protection sociale grâce à de faux
dossier et avec des identités factice
des personnes qui ne sont pas ou plus
réside en France et qui ont conserver
des droits ouverte de manière illégal
voir des bénéficiaires dit fantôme non
identifiable Patrick Hetzel députés et
président de la commission d'enquête
parlementaire relative à la lutte contre
la fraude aux prestations sociales a
longuement enquêter sur ce sur nombre
d'assurés et confirme une partie de
cette hypothèse ce qui est certain c'est
que nous nous sommes rendu
avec une liste de d'identité dans
l'avion qu'il s'agissait de fausse
identité et là nous avons pu nous le
rendre compte que 15 % de ses feuilles
d'identité avait donné lieu à une une
immatriculation par le sens bien sur ce
point aucune estimation du montant des
dépenses d'un justifier pour cette
personne n'a pu être établie
mais cette première donné ne reflète pas
à elle seule le montant de la fraude à
l'assurance maladie en 2019 le montant
des préjudices subis et éviter au titre
de fraude et de fautes détecté par
l'assurance maladie a atteint
286,7 million d'euros dans ce montant
des 71,3 million d'assurer représente 21
% du montant total du préjudice subi
cesser assurer fraudeur plusieurs types
de procédés ont été identifiés les plus
courants sont la fraude à l'ouverture de
droit à une prise en charge des frais de
santé la falsification de documents
comme les ordonnances ou encore la
fraude sur les arrêts de travail et le
cumulus d'indemnités journalières ça ce
sont les photos des assurés sociaux il
faut avoir bien conscience en matière
d'assurance maladie il y a aussi
énormément de fraude des professionnels
de santé on a un taux de 13 % de fraude
supposer sur les infirmiers libéraux sur
les masseur kinésithérapeute le taux est
supérieur à 5 % la même manière et sur
les médecins généralistes le taux est
supérieur à 3 %
établi par la Cour des comptes qui
estimer un taux de remboursement maximum
au-delà duquel le professionnel de santé
n'as pas une activité normale les
fraudes est des professionnels des
établissements de santé concentre
finalement plus des trois quarts du
montant des fraudes à l'assurance
maladie les travaux au monte qu'il n'y a
aucune catégorie
qui qui n'échappe en fait tu as la
c'est-à-dire que
vous avez des boutons noirs dans ton
chaque profession alors comment faire
pour juguler c'est fraude pour cela
plusieurs pistes sont étudiés dont une
en particulier c'est l'identité sociale
sécurisé par la biométrie la Caisse
nationale de l'assurance maladie et
ainsi pousser à se digitalisé un projet
de déploiement d'une carte Vitale
dématérialisé par exemple à l'étude
depuis 2 ans et tester dans 10
départements depuis le 1er octobre 2021
l'intérêt et finalement de conditionner
le versement est le bénéfice de toutes
ces prestations sociales à la
vérification de l'identité sociale par
la biométrie un autre outil qui
permettrait de lutter contre déjà fait
ses preuves dans plusieurs pays européen
comme l'Espagne et la dématérialisation
des ordonnances médicales
l'ordonnance à une carte Vitale par
exemple le pharmacien peut lire
l'ordonnance mais il n'y a plus de
support papier donc vous supprimer ce
risque de fausse ordonnance la première
estimation complète de la fraude à
l'assurance maladie et aujourd'hui
encore en cours de calcul